[Musique]
non
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
des matins du sénat l'émission qui vous
fait vivre les travaux de la haute
assemblée pendant cette crise sanitaire
du coroner virus une crise due
coronavirus qui est d'ampleur
internationale
et justement les sénateurs ont
auditionné le ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères jean yves le
drian
je vous laisse écouter cette audition
nous sommes ravis à double à double
titre d'une part pour les quelques
heureux qui m'entoure de nous retrouver
ici dans notre salle de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées et donc chacun de vos
groupe est représenté par quelques
collègues qui étaient ici pour les
questions au gouvernement notamment
et puis monsieur mais on est heureux de
vous retrouver ici parce qu'on a
l'impression que la vie reprend et quel
que soit l'intérêt de la visioconférence
est quand même plus agréable de devoir
des visages mais je salue bien
évidemment nos collègues qui sont par
visioconférence reliés à cette salle qui
n'a pas bougé et qui vous attend tous
bien évidemment monsieur le ministre
merci d'avoir accepté cette réunion
selon la nouvelle formule
on peut dire au temps où nous sommes que
avant la crise du coc vis de la
situation du monde était déjà alarmante
le recul du multilatéralisme le jeu
exacerbée des puissances avec une
tentation croissant d'un certain nombre
de pays de recourir à la force ou au
fait accompli
la remise en cause du modèle des
démocraties libérales l'émergence d'une
menace climatique global nous nous
souvenons tous là un peu comme de
l'ancien temps malheureusement en
l'occurrence les choses n'ont pas
franchement changé et nous pouvons même
dire que la très gris la très grave
crise que nous vivons actuellement à
plutôt empiré les choses sur à peu près
tous les plans certaines lignes de force
s'accentue
d'autres apparaissent soudainement se
sont en fait ces bouleversements que
l'on voudrait analyser avec vous
aggravation des crises est évidemment
bien sûr la situation au sahel qui nous
inquiète car même si l'actualité et les
médias ont focalisé sur la crise du coc
vide
il s'est passé beaucoup d'événements
traîtrise des attentats et notamment
dernièrement avec des pertes parmi nos
nos amis des forces armées africaines le
choc épidémique évidemment que nous
redoutions en afrique ne s'est pas
produit pour l'instant mais sur le plan
sécuritaire et sur le plan économique le
continent n'est pas épargné par tous
partout
le terrorisme se durcit alors vous nous
direz monsieur le ministre si la
dynamique du sommet de pau qui avait été
comme un un espoir
si cette dynamique va résister à la
crise du coc vis desquels la situation
quel est votre votre analyse de la
situation au sahel
on pense aussi bien sûr au levant entre
une menace terroriste qui se reconstitue
la poursuite par le régime de damas et
ses soutiens d'un travail de reconquête
sur l'ensemble du territoire et aussi
bien sûr on ne peut pas oublier les
graves inquiétudes sur le conflit
israélo palestinien que nous avions
évoqués du reste longuement ici avec
vous le 3 mars dernier avec une
perspective d'annexion de la cisjordanie
dont vous avez déclaré qu'elle ne
pourrait nous laisser sans réaction et
vous même sans réponse
vous nous direz quel est la réponse du
gouvernement est la réponse de la france
voilà vous n'êtes pas venu pour rien et
que dans le même temps là aussi une
tension très nette ses heures et ces
jours derniers en libye avec une
intervention maintenant de l'aviation
russe est ce qu'on va de plus en plus
vers un scénario à la syrienne en libye
vous nous donnerez vos analyses
et puis face à la montée de ces de ces
périls et au choc de la crise
on peut dire que l'europe a fait quand
même malgré quelques points positifs
mais elle a fait plutôt la démonstration
de son impuissance de ses divisions au
moins dans les premiers temps la france
oeuvrent actuellement à structurer
désormais une réponse plus forte et
mieux coordonnée de l'union vous allez
nous dire où nous en sommes
quels sont les points de blocage quelles
sont les perspectives
et pour surmonter ces points de blocage
quand et comment les frontières vont
elles rouvriront voit ici ou là encore
dans le désordre un certain nombre de
pays qui annonce des ouvertures de
frontières mais l'europe aurait tout
intérêt à travailler ensemble
nous sommes évidemment assez pessimiste
quant aux chances de succès des
négociations entre michel barnier et le
royaume uni sera prochainement ici au
mois de
juin pour nous faire part de
l'avancement de ces négociations pour
autant qu'elles avancent la sphère de la
quarantaine et désole et désolante et
quel est votre pronostic pour le
prochain round de négociations enfin
dans un tableau général assez sombre on
assiste là aussi à travers des
déclarations assez tonitruante à la
confrontation entre les états unis et la
chine
cette confrontation continue de prendre
de l'ampleur on parle même maintenant
d'une nouvelle guerre froide est ce que
c'est exagéré quelles sont les limites
et jusqu'où peut-on aller dans cette
tension et surtout une fois de plus quel
rôle la france et quel rôle l'europe
peuvent-ils jouer dans un monde qui
pourrait finalement redevenir bipolaire
voilà quelques questions quelques
inquiétudes que nous avons et que nous
partageons avec vous mais vous nous
direz un peu où vous en êtes et quels
sont les éléments d analyse que vous
nous proposez
je rappelle que cette audition est
diffusé actuellement en direct sur le
site du sénat
selon une procédure que vous connaissez
bien je vais vous donner la parole dans
quelques instants monsieur le ministre
puis après nous donnerons la parole aux
groupes politiques avec des
représentants de chacun de ces groupes
soient par visio soit qu'ils soient
présents ici avec une légère
modification par rapport au
fonctionnement deux de ses représentants
de groupes issus des décisions de notre
bureau
et puis vous aurez l'occasion de
répondre
et puis si le temps
nous le permet et vous le permet les
sénateurs autre que les représentants
des groupes compléteront par des
questions sachant que notre collègue
cigolotti peut-être sera conduit à
assurer la fin de la séance puisque
malheureusement j'ai un engagement
impératif l'élection d'un maire auquel
je dois absolument assister tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs lui ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette deuxième rencontre de pendant
la crise de la pandémie
la première était totalement virtuel
nous sommes en semi déconfinement ou
semi confinement comme vous le souhaitez
mais enfin c'est toujours tout à fait
agréable de venir vous rencontrer
vous avez évoqué monsieur le président
l'aggravation des crises je dois dire
que on pourrait résumer la situation en
disant que pendant la pandémie les
crises continue et non seulement ils
continuent mais d'une certaine manière
elle s'aggrave puisque les rivalités de
puissance et les stratégies de puissance
non seulement se maintiennent mais se
continue par d'autres moyens
c'est ça qui est tout à fait nouveau et
ça nous fait réfléchir au monde d'après
j'avais eu l'occasion de dire qu' il
faudrait éviter que le monde d'après
soit autre chose que le monde d'avant
empire
je ne suis pas sûr que ce sera le cas
en tout cas il faut pour éviter cela en
particulier dans la confrontation
majeure qui s'est fait jour au cours des
dernières semaines entre les états unis
et la chine
faire en sorte que l'union européenne
prenne sa place et ne reçoit pas
l'observatrice laprise prise en otage
entre cette nouvelle confrontation
mondiale que de grandes puissances
veulent essayer de mettre en oeuvre et
puisse affirmer à la fois sa capacité
d'initiative et sa souveraineté
et c'est la conviction profonde que j'ai
et je devrais commencer par quelques
observations sur l'union européenne je
ne partage pas totalement une fois n'est
pas coutume monsieur le président votre
pessimisme sur la manière dont l'union
européenne a géré la crise même si la
fin de votre propos étaient plus
optimistes
il y a eu vis-à-vis de la crise
certainement du retard à l'allumage dans
la machinerie européenne et je crois que
ce retard est dû à trois paramètres
le premier c'est que les questions
sanitaires les enjeux de santé n'ont
jamais été dans les compétences au coeur
des compétences de l'union européenne si
un organisme qui est basé à skokie un
peu ce rôle
et donc il n'y a pas une mobilisation
immédiate sur ces jeunes sur ces enjeux
de la part de l'union européenne
ensuite parce que la pandémie était une
crise que personne ne pouvait anticiper
dans son ampleur et c'est assez un peu
plus tard que la dimension dramatique a
pu être perçue et enfin parce que la
pandémie s'est développée en europe de
manière progressive
touchant d'abord certains pays plus que
d'autres et épargnants certains pays et
pas d'autres pour des raisons que sans
doute les scientifiques pourront nous
expliquer un jour quand on analysera
lent lent l'évolution de la pandémie sur
les spas l'espace européen
en tout cas si dans un premier temps les
rendez vous n'ont pas été parfait je
dois dire que depuis la fin du mois de
mars
on peut considérer que les institutions
européennes se sont au rendez vous en
tout cas je considère pour ma part que
les institutions européennes sont au
rendez vous l union européenne a été au
rendez vous d'abord immédiatement pour
gérer la crise avec une aide budgétaire
d'urgence de 3 milliards d'euros avec
notamment pour le sanitaire avec la
mobilisation immédiate des des fonds
structurels redirigés vers des dépenses
d'urgence avec des achats groupés de
matane de protection avec 1 milliard
d'euros d'investissements dans la
recherche avec la mobilisation immédiate
de 750 milliards d'euros de rachats de
dette par la bce cela a été fait dans
l'immédiateté comme dans l'immédiateté
on a pu assister à l'assouplissement des
règles relatives aux aides d'état et
règles relatives au pacte de stabilité
et de croissance et sa crosse 1 3% dans
un premier temps il ya eu pour gérer la
crise
une série d'initiatives assez forte un
peu inespéré d'ailleurs dans dans leur
ampleur et nole dans leur rapidité et
ensuite il y a eu des mesures à deuxième
tente de mesures qui ont été prises pour
gérer les conséquences de la crise en
mobilisant 540 milliards d'euros à la
fois sous forme de prêt à la fois pour
les entreprises avec le fonds de
garantie de la banque européenne
d'investissement de 100 milliards
d'euros avec eux aussi pour les états
des lignes de crédit dans le cadre du
mécanisme européen de stabilité sans
conditionnalité ce qui ne fait pas du
tout le cas de des crises antérieures
et puis avec aussi le dispositif qui
s'appelle shourd qui mobilise 100
milliards d'euros pour aider la mise en
oeuvre du chômage partiel pour les
salariés européens
c'était la deuxième étape est maintenant
on est à la troisième étape qui doit
amener l'europe à à réagir pour préparer
l'avenir et relancer l'économie c'est
dans ce cadre là que le président de la
république et la chancelière ont
présenté le 18 mai dernier une
initiative franco allemande pour une
réponse européenne
on a cette initiative repose sur quatre
piliers on a surtout insisté sur le
fonds de relance je vais y revenir mais
ont parfois on a tendance à oublier les
autres piliers qui ont été au coeur de
cette communication de cette volonté
d'abord l'affirmation de la souveraineté
européenne sur le terrain de la santé la
prise en compte de cet enjeu la prise en
compte de la souveraineté dans le
domaine de la santé avec notamment
volonté d'avoir des stocks stratégiques
communs de masques de tests de d'avoir
des capacités d'achat et des capacités
de production commune des capacités de
coordination de pour la recherche pour
les traitements et vaccins
des plans de prévention des épidémies
des méthodes communes pour identifier
les cas tout ça c'est le premier paquet
puis un peu passée sous silence dans les
initiatives qui ont été proposées il y
avait le 2
deuxième paquet dont on a beaucoup parlé
qu'est la création d'un fonds de relance
pour mettre en oeuvre la solidarité
européenne dans la réponse à la crise
les fameux 500 milliards d'euros
financée par de la dette levée sur les
marchés financiers par la commission
européenne qui devrait permettre de
financer via le budget européen des
dépenses budgétaires et c'est la
proposition franco-allemande à cet égard
étaient concentrés sur les premières
années du futur cadre financier
pluriannuel 2021 et 2027
ainsi la commission pourrait emprunter
sur les marchés financiers au nom de
l'europe ce qui est une première et
c'est un pas que chacun a pu constater
très significatif de l'initiative franco
allemande
j'observe c'est un petit peu tôt pour en
faire le commentaire puisque ce n'est
que en ce moment même que madame
vaudrait rien fait sa conférence de
presse sur les contours du de la réunion
de la commission qui s'est tenue ce
matin sur la proposition de la
commission pour la dame de la nouvelle
donne du cadre financier pluriannuel
mais j'observe simplement d'après les
informations que je peux avoir même si
je ne peux pas répondre à des questions
sur l'ensemble du dispositif puisque il
devrait en sortir
mais j'observe simplement que la
proposition des 500 millions d'euros est
prise en compte comme elle l'avait été
annoncé et sa soeur comme milliards
d'euros pardon comme l avait été annoncé
initialement dans un paquet de deux
plans de relance qui tourne autour de
750 milliards d'euros
lorsque tout ça nécessitera une
discussion y compris la nouille les
nouvelles orientations du cadre
financier pluriannuel
mais je ne peux qu observer qu'il ya eu
là une initiative forte qui se traduit
par des engagements de la commission qui
seront soumis à la discussion des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement qui se tiendra
dans la deuxième partie du mois de juin
le 18 ou le 19 juin
normalement il y avait ce deuxième
paquet y avait un troisième paquet qui
était qui insistait sur l'accélération
la transition écologique de la
transition numérique et donc qui
manifesté la volonté de ne pas remettre
en cause les priorités que l'europe cité
des données pour permettre d'investir
massivement dans ces domaines qui
permettra à l'europe de faire la
différence dans les années qui viennent
par rapport à d'autres espaces
économiques au niveau mondial
et puis quatrièmement il a été affirmé
par la chancelière à l'eau présente dans
le public
la nécessité du renforcement de la
souveraineté économique et industriel de
l'europe avec la nécessité de déterminer
quels sont les biens qui ont pour nous
une importance stratégique d'identifier
nos vulnérabilités de montrer les
secteurs où une fois affirmer notre
propre souveraineté
je pense en particulier au domaine
sanitaire alimentaire mais aussi n'est
aussi numérique et de faire en sorte que
désormais les règles de la concurrence
les priorités d'investissement
permettent à l'europe d'affirmer cette
nouvelle configuration de nos chaînes de
valeur ce n'est pas secondaire que de
voir les deux chefs d'état de
gouvernement des pays les plus
importants de l'union européenne
d'affirmer ses orientations nogué a eu
sa alors maintenant toujours dit j'ai d
ici là dans une réunion précédente je
crois que vous pouvez imaginer que la
crise pouvait une forme d' accélérateur
de refondation pour l'europe il y à des
briques qui se met en place qui peuvent
re je l'espère permettent cette nouvelle
donne je voudrais revenir aussi puisque
vous il y avait convié
c'est un sujet à la fois européen
français international sur la question
des frontières
essayez de dire les choses clairement
s'il ya beaucoup de confusion sur ce
sujet ou sur ces sujets il ya d'abord
une clarification simple que vous
connaissez mais que je veux redire
puisque une somme en public c'est le
fait que jusqu'à nouvel ordre
l'espace européen et les frontières de
l'espace et européennes hors biens sont
fermés
pour le reste du monde et c'est les vals
cela est valable jusqu'au 15 juin il est
vraisemblable que cela se prolongera ce
qui veut dire que les français qui sont
à l'extérieur de l'espace européen quand
je dis l'espace européen pour l'instant
avec des nuances qu'il faudra sans doute
que j'apporte dans la discussion c'est à
la fois l'espace schengen les pays lieux
qui ne sont pas dans schengen plus le
royaume uni c'était cela la les
frontières extérieures sont fermées ce
qui veut dire ça peut surprendre que à
partir du moment où désormais nous
sommes nous en face nous la france et
pour les pays concernés ils ont aussi
des règles qui concernent leur niveau
déconfinement puisque nous sommes en
déconfinement désormais nous demandons à
nos propres ressortissants qui
reviennent en france
ils ont toujours la liberté de le faire
de ce s'imposer eux mêmes une
quatorzaine pour assurer la protection
de leurs proches et pour faire en sorte
qu'ils assurent aussi leur propre
protection de la protection de
l'environnement
il ya des mécanismes qui sont explicités
dans les avions les aéroports pour
permettre pour permettre aux cela c'est
parce que il ya le déconfinement pouvait
s'interroger pourquoi pas avant parce
qu'avant c'était le confinement et donc
quand vous reveniez même si les
frontières étaient fermés vous rentriez
vous confiné aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
cas et donc c'est pourquoi s'il ya cette
mesure qui a été prise sur les
frontières
donc ce processus va durer pour s en
blanc au delà du 15 juin
même si c'est une décision collective
qu'il faudra mettre en oeuvre et donc du
coup ce dispositif de 14 n se poursuivre
il est même possible qui soit plus
rigoureux
sid aventure d'ici le 15 juin
les pays de l'union européenne identifie
les pays à l'égard nous desquels nous
devrions apporter une vigilance
particulière pour ce qui reviendrait de
ces pays là
au cours de la période suivante puisque
progressivement l'évolution est plutôt
positive en europe et donc il nous
faudra nous protéger d'autres ça
arrivait d'autres pays donc imposé
peut-être une quatorzième plus strictes
à ce moment là j'espère que le fait bien
comprendre mais c'est beau tout ça c'est
du bon sens
sur la partie intérieure de l'union
européenne
là il y a eu un traitement spécifique
des différents pays en raison de
l'évolution de la pandémie ce de l'or
l'agenda de la pandémie si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi
pour traiter cette question en fonction
de l'évolution du virus et de la gravité
certains pays ont subi la pandémie plus
tôt je pense à l'italie et donc le
déconfinement et plus précoces et donc
les mesures aux frontières puisque pour
l'instant il les frontières n'était pas
fermée mais il y avait des contrôles
spécifiques avec des dérogations qui
était apportée que nous avons nous mêmes
à porter pour un certain nombre de nos
de nos compatriotes
et bien cela aboutit à ce que ils
prennent des dispositions avant d'autres
et puis certains ont été très peu touché
par la pandémie
donc on ne pouvait pas imaginer des
règles générales pour tout le monde
puisque la coordination ne signifie pas
l'uniformité puisque le mal et était
traité différemment et son évolution
était différente selon les pays donc
nous sommes dans une logique qui va
aboutir
je l'espère à d assouplissement
progressif jusqu'au 15 juin
assouplissement qui ne pourront être
mises en oeuvre que lorsqu'on aura les
éléments de constats sanitaires et les
éléments 2d des scientifiques nous
permettant de le faire et à cet égard
les décisions qui seront prises à la fin
de semaine pour la phase qui va s'ouvrir
à partir du 2 juin seront tout à fait
déterminante à la fois sur les limites
des 100 km à la fois sur les
la dynamique touristique mais aussi sur
le niveau de progression dans
l'assouplissement pour les frontières
puis à partir du 15 juin on sera en
mesure de juger les effets de la
nouvelle phase de déconfinement qui va
s'ouvrir le 2 puisque vous connaissez le
lady mulet dix jours d'incubation et
d'attentes nécessaire pour observer les
évolutions et alors on pourra je
l'espère être dans une situation
beaucoup plus sereine nous concernant
cette posture là elle vaut pour la
france n'ont pas fermé les frontières
nous sommes deux des citations de
contrôle assoupli progressivement
si un état riverain prend des mesures
différentes bien nous considérons qu'il
faut faire la réciprocité et c'est la
raison pour laquelle pour répondre à
votre interrogation monsieur le
président appartement ou le royaume-uni
a décidé de changer de posture
nous faisons la réciprocité c'était
aussi le cas pour l'espagne mais notre
principe de base et celui là j'espère
avoir été assez claire parce qu'il ya
souvent beaucoup de confusion sur ces
sujets et j'espère que cette
progressivité qui est fait à la fois de
volonté d'ouverture mais en même temps
de grande prudence pour éviter parce que
ce que chacun redoute une deuxième vague
potentiel pour que tout cela puisse se
dérouler normalement et que nos
compatriotes puissent passer un été plus
agréable que la période de confinement
je voudrais aussi insisté sur un autre
point
concernant la lutte contre le virus mais
aussi l'action mondiale concernant les
questions de de santé parce que à cet
égard il y a eu deux initiatives qui
dans le débat qui dans le débat général
sont passés peut-être un peu inaperçu et
sur lesquels je voudrais revenir et
d'abord eu l'initiative que nous avons
prise ce qui s'appelle l'initiative acta
prise par le président de la république
avec la coordination de l'union
européenne le 24 avril dernier en
relation aussi avec le directeur général
de l'om est-ce qu'ils étaient deux
mobiliser des financements pour lutter
contre le coronavirus mais surtout pour
appuyer la généralisation des
diagnostics l'action de recherche sur
les traitements et l'action de recherche
sur les vaccins contre le coc vide de 19
cette initiative majeure qui a rassemblé
tous ceux qui peuvent contribuer à cette
tâche essentielle c'est à dire à la fois
le ms mais aussi les organisations
financières internationales
les acteurs privés les fonds multi
mondiaux comme le fonds mondial sur le
contre le sida l'alliance gavi
l'industrie pharmaceutique des
fondations bref beaucoup d'acteurs qui
ont permis de mobiliser 7 3 milliards
d'euros grâce à une conférence des
bailleurs qui s'est tenue au début du
mois de mai la france et contribueront
pour sa part à 500 auteurs de 510
millions d'euros
ces diagnostics ces traitements ce
vaccin nous ne battons pas seulement
pour qu'il voie le jour mais aussi pour
qu'ils deviennent des biens publics
mondiaux
c'est à dire des biens accessible à tous
sans exception et des biens que personne
ne puisse prétendre s'arroger et c'est
un point essentiel nous avons besoin
d'un autre modèle économique et
juridique que celui de la concurrence et
de la compétition sur ces sujets là il
faut mettre en oeuvre un modèle de
collaboration précis avec des règles du
jeu que chacun de voir respectés y
compris des acteurs privés et c'est le
sens d'acta avec ses quatre priorités
l'accès universel à un prix raisonnable
des vaccins du vaccin quand il arrivera
des traitements quand ils arriveront des
diagnostics la production en quantité
suffisante pour ne laisser personne de
côté lorsque les vaccins seront mises à
disposition
la location des stocks non pas en
fonction des maps du marche du marché
mais en fonction des besoins
l'utilisation optimale des ressources
privées et publiques dans une logique de
transparence la mutualisation des
brevets et le partage des savoirs et des
savoir faire et ça c'est une avancée
considérable
il importera maintenant de faire en
sorte que nous puissions par une forme
de charte
aboutir à ce que cet ensemble là soit
vraiment concrétisé et c'est sur cette
base là que nous avons agi au sein de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
tenu son assemblée plénière mondial la
semaine dernière en virtuel avec
quelques complications mais enfin elle
s'est tenue
et parce que nous pensons nous étions
présents très très actif sur ce set
cette assemblée mondiale de la santé
parce que nous considérons que nous
devons faire bloc autour de l' oms le ms
a sans doute des manques mais
aujourd'hui c'est la seule organisation
de santé public universel dont nous
disposons pour faire face à la pandémie
et donc il faut considérer que c'est
l'outil a passé 2 qu'elle nous devons
travailler pour assurer une action
mondiale dans le domaine de la santé en
particulier contre les pandémies et
singulièrement le coït 19 et nous avons
engagé propositions pour faire en sorte
que le ms puisse se transformer parce
qu'il importe qu'elle peut se
transformer dans l'avenir l'assemblée
générale se poursuivra jusqu'à la fin de
cette année on l'espère en présentiel à
la fin de l'année nous avons pour notre
part
quatre priorités que voulons voir mettre
en oeuvre par le ms d'abord faire en
sorte que le msm d'un rôle normatif plus
ferme aujourd'hui comme vous le savez il
existe un règlement sanitaire
international dont le msc le garant il
ya des ferries mécanisme de vérification
mais il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de moyens
de d'imposer un certain nombre
d'éléments aux membres de l' oms pour
que le règlement sanitaire international
puisse se mettre en oeuvre a pas
vraiment une garantie d'applications
réelles sur le terrain par par les états
donc il faut renforcer ce rôle normatif
il faut renforcer son rôle d' alerte
ce qui suppose de donner l oms les
moyens de vérifier de façon indépendante
les informations sanitaires transmises
par les états et
dans cet état d'esprit nous avons
proposé la création d'un haut conseil
mondial sur la santé humaine et animale
qui serait chargé d'alerter les
gouvernements et d'informer les sociétés
comme un peu comme le fait le giec pour
le climat le giec ne prend pas les
mesures
mais le giec alerte parce que il est
respecté étant constituée d'un certain
nombre de grands experts scientifiques
mondiaux qui disent ce qu'ils voient ce
qu'ils sentent qu'ils appuient leur
raisonnement sur des données
scientifiques faut qu'il y ait la même
chose au niveau au niveau de la santé
articulée sur le msm avec l'indépendance
nécessaire pour que c'est au conseil
puisse affirmer les réalités et nous
pensions utile de le mettre en
articulation avec un santé animale je ne
fais pas de dos rétrospectif sur le
sujet mais je pense que c'est tout à
fait utile de mettre les deux nés de
ensemble pour que ce soit un outil de
dallaire la france par notre
intermédiaire à proposer cette
initiative et enfin il nous faut aussi
renforcer les moyens financiers de l'om
est-ce pour que l'om est puisse être
indépendante dans son fonctionnement et
la france a décidé d'apporter une
contribution supplémentaire d'au moins
50 millions d'euros c'est important un
moment où en particulier les etats-unis
ont décidé de renoncer à leurs
contributions complémentaires
aujourd'hui à le masquer le ms vie sur
essentiellement contribution
complémentaire volontaire
les contributions aux terres le msv sur
un ratio de financement qui est le ratio
de financement des nations unies mais
qui est une base extrêmement faible et
le reste de son action et peut se
développer par des contributions
volontaires c'est ce qui fait la la
substance de l' oms mais ce qui peut
faire aussi ses risques
et quand tel ou tel pays décident de
s'en retirer
nous avons aussi souhaité je parle de
l'om est ce parce qu'on n'en parle pas
beaucoup dans réunions de commissions
des affaires étrangères jusqu'à présent
ne parlait pas beaucoup on voit bien que
c'est un enjeu majeur maintenant nous
avons souhaité aussi que l'on puisse
renforcer le rôle de la formation avec
la création à lyon d'une académie de la
santé de l'eau oms avait été annoncé au
moment du sommet de du fonds mondial
pour le sida à lyon il ya relativement
peu de temps c'était à l'automne dernier
et cette nécessité encore plus
importante maintenant qui hier à ces
efforts là il y a eu je prends un
relatif consensus qui s'est manifestée
au cours de l'assemblée générale
avec aussi la volonté commune de mettre
en oeuvre une évaluation indépendante
les mots sont importants globale et
impartial de la pandémie depuis son
début jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de la
pandémie qui sera initiée après la
demande de l'assemblée générale de
mettre en oeuvre cette évaluation
il n'y a pas eu de blocage alors que
nous étions dans une situation très
conflictuelle y compris la délégation
chinoise a donné son accord cette option
et les états unis ne s'y sont pas
opposés
donc je considère que la cette
initiative de la france initiative
partagée par les européens et qui a
abouti à ce résultat qui est une avancée
significative là aussi comme pour atta
maintenant c'est comment on pèse pour
que ses grands engagements puisse être
concrétisé
je n'ai pas de raison de penser
aujourd'hui que cela pourra pas se
mettre en oeuvre je voudrais dire
quelques mots sur l'afrique
or en complément de ce que je viens de
dire est toujours autour de la dimension
internationale de la pandémie
vous avez vous avez souligné monsieur le
président c'est ce que nous constatons
aussi que finalement la pandémie semble
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui épargné plus l'afrique pour
des raisons là aussi que vous n'en dites
du mal à parfois identifié certes on
peut il on peut imaginer que il y à une
détection un moins importante
qu'ailleurs mais ça n'explique pas le
faible taux de pénétration
heureusement même s'il ya des signes
dans certains pays pensent au cameroun
je conseille les gîtes chance à
l'afrique du sud où ça devient un petit
peu inquiétant mais néanmoins
globalement le la menace cataclysme que
l'on imaginait je l'avais même dit ici
dans une une réunion précédente ne naît
pas n'est pas au rendez vous pour
l'instant et tant mieux pour une fois
ceci étant la difficulté pour pour
l'afrique c'est de d'anticiper les
risques et aussi d'anticiper les
conséquences
humanitaires de la crise pandémique en
raison en particulier de l'absence de
connexion transport de logistique de qui
est lié à fermeture des lignes aériennes
aux blocages des transports et aux
fermetures des frontières et donc à cet
égard nous avons pris une initiative a
au mois d'avril avec 18 dirigeants
européens et africains pour une
mobilisation mondiale pour aider
l'afrique à affronter la crise dans
toutes ses dimensions avec quatre enjeux
je reviendrai éventuellement le soutien
aux systèmes de santé nationaux
la france va renforcer son aide
bilatérale
à cet égard sur la fait que les systèmes
de santé nationaux avec des
mobilisations à hauteur de 1 milliard
200 millions pour la france la fille et
l'activité économique avec des
initiatives importantes et ambitieuse
qui ont été prises je pense aux
moratoires sur les dettes
ces 20 milliards ce sous réserve qu'ils
soient affectés et qui permettent aux
états africains ça c'est fait qui
permettent aux états africains de se
mobiliser davantage pour assurer la leur
sécurité sanitaire il reste que nous
souhaitons aller au delà et faire en
sorte qu'il puisse y avoir une
annulation des dettes pour certains pays
qui puisse y avoir une mobilisation de
droits de tirage spéciaux pour d'autres
afin de permettre aux pays africains de
passer cette période difficile 3e
troisième aspect de l'engagement qui a
été pris par cette initiative du mois du
mois d'avril une réponse humanitaire
significative et là nous avons pris nous
mêmes l'initiative de créer un pont
humanitaire aérien européen avec
l'afrique pour acheminer des fournitures
d matériel et du personnel dans les pays
les plus en difficulté
en relation étroite avec le commissaire
dinars chick un premier vol a eu lieu le
8 mai au départ de lyon avec notre
soutien et notre préparation à
destination de la république
centrafricaine un deuxième vol a eu lieu
depuis et il l'est prévu 30 vols pour
permettre l'aide de deux pays européens
au pluriel pour veut aider l'afrique à
passer cette étape difficile moi même je
vais me rendre en république
démocratique du congo dans quelques
jours pour parce que maintenant que les
dispositions de permettre de le faire
avec mon homologue belge pour apporter
cette aide humanitaire à ces pays le
secrétaire d'état mais de mon chien va
se rendre dans le même dispositif au
burkina faso bref il ya là une
initiative considérable y compris dans
le narratif à l'égard des pays africains
nous sommes là les européens sont là les
la france est là et dans cette période
difficile on apporte notre soutien de
manière très significative
les premiers résultats que nous avons pu
constater en particulier l'a
immédiatement en république
centrafricaine ont été très positifs
enfin quatrième point le soutien à l'
expertise scientifique africaine
notamment grâce à la mobilisation nous
agence de recherche et grâce au réseau
de nos dix instituts pasteur en afrique
cette initiative là elle est à la fois
initiatives de solidarité lié à notre
histoire en particulier mais c'est aussi
notre propre intérêt sanitaire est ce
que si l' aventure la pandémie était
enrayée en europe et qu'elle se
développait en afrique alors
finalement nos propres intérêts ont été
ont été contrebalancés donc il faut lier
solidarité et intérêts collectifs et
intérêt mondial dans cette affaire voilà
les points que je voulais souligner
parce qu'on n'en parle pas souvent et je
pense que ces bonnes bonnes opportunités
d'évoquer la dimension sanitaire
international qui met à l'ordre du jour
par l'évolution de la pandémie
alors monsieur le président vous avez
évoqué plusieurs situations de crise je
ne vais pas et j'ai dit tout à l'heure
en commençant que pendant la pandémie
les crises continuer je vais pas tout
les évoquer mais mon réservant ça peut
être plutôt aux questions mais mais
quand même quelques unes qui sont un peu
au coeur de l'actualité mal malgré tout
aujourd'hui j'avais évoqué le sahel je
suis moins pessimiste que vous sur la
situation
je suis moins pessimiste que je ne l'aï
été moi même dans le dans le passé parce
que nous avons pu en visioconférence
tenir une réunion avec les ministres la
défense et des affaires étrangères des
cinq pays du sahel il ya quelques jours
et j'ai constaté d'abord la reprise des
comités de suivi de l'accord de paix au
mali après cinq mois de suspension
j'ai constaté leur déploiement
progressif des forces armées maliennes
dans les régions du nord y compris à
kidal ce qui s'était jamais passé
on ne le sait pas parce que tout ça
passe derrière le le coronavirus mai
le premier bataillon de l'armée malienne
officielle s'est installé à kidal
ce n'était pas le cas depuis 2013
je constate aussi que les élections
législatives se sont tenues au mali sans
trop de contestations et que malgré un
contexte sécuritaire et sanitaire
difficile
je constate aussi que il y à une
coordination efficace entre barkan la
force conjointe du g5 et les les armées
nationales dans le cadre de deux
opérations qui ont été menées
singulièrement dans la zone des trois
frontières et que dans la zone des trois
frontières et la zone privilégiée de
l'action du g5 et de la force conjointe
du g5
le rapport de force a changé ce qui
montre que il y a eu des victoires sur
les groupes terroristes de la part des
forces du g5 et donc on voit bien que le
défi est toujours là mais il ya une
dynamique qui est utile et qui permet
une je pense une bonne efficacité et
puis en complément de cela la coalition
pour le sel dont le principe avait
décidé décidé à pau mois de janvier se
mettre en oeuvre puisque nous avons
lancé cette coalition lors d'une réunion
en visioconférence avec le président
mauritanien am sera soigné est le
président du conseil européen charles
michel et nous allons maintenant aboutir
à une réunion ministérielle de la
coalition sahel avec josep borrell le
haut commissaire le haut représentant et
mon collègue mauritanien dans quelques
jours et donc la montée en puissance de
cette coalition est fondamental parce
qu'elles amplifient et coordonne bien
les efforts en cours donc je suis j'ai
été plus pessimiste
voilà pour pour résumer les choses il y
aura des rendez vous à venir en
particulier dans un rendez-vous à
nouakchott
au début du mois de juillet je crois
c'est ça début des matches et j'espère
qu'on pourra le faire en présentiel et
et pour pour faire un point un point
général même si c'est toujours fragile
même si on constate aussi des rivalités
maintenant entre les groupes terroristes
entre mairie et remit jamais et oui ges
et singulièrement la proximité de la
zone des trois frontières constate aussi
des instrumentalisations ethnique à
l'intérieur même de la confrontation
entre les groupes terroristes l'un étant
lié à al-qaïda l'hôte étant lié à l'état
islamique mais ses divisions aboutissent
aussi au fait que le rapport de force
est en train de changer
je touche du bois je trouve que ça va un
peu mieux et il faut le noter
je n'oublie pas en vous parlant de cela
la situation de soumaïla cissé néanmoins
qui est leader de grands leaders de
l'opposition au mali et qui est toujours
enlevé depuis maintenant plus de deux
mois avril mai ils prennent pas de plus
de deux mois alors qu'il était en
campagne dans sa circonscription et nous
avons joint nous appellent aux autorités
maliennes pour obtenir sa libération
je vais dire quelques mots sur la libye
ou alors là
je reste très très pessimiste
les combats se poursuivent il y avait eu
un accord à berlin c'était au mois de
janvier et à berlin
il y avait un accord assez général en
présence de tout le monde que ce soit my
pompéo que ce soit le président 6,6 que
ce soit le président erdogan que ce soit
l'ama chancelière le président macron je
vais pas énumérer tous les participants
et le président algérien et finalement
on avait trouvé un accord et une feuille
de route qui supposait la trêve la
transformation de la trêve en cessez le
feu
le processus de dialogue interlibyen est
un dispositif économique permettant
d'éviter que les bleu pétrole soit
bloquée et que
les richesses propres de la libye ne
soient dirigées que faire tel ou tel
groupe
et puis entraînant aussi la mise en
oeuvre par l'union européenne d'un
mécanisme pour lutter contre pour
permettre l'embargo sur les armes
tout ça faisait partie d'un ensemble qui
était actée par toulon mais ça ne s'est
pas mise en place et quand je disais
tout à l'heure
pendant la pandémie les crises continue
là la crise s'aggrave
puisque nous sommes je n'ai pas peur du
mot devant une signalisation de la libye
aujourd'hui avec 102 les initiatives
pour que je ne vais pas porter de
jugement sur les uns sur les autres mais
en tout cas sérialisation pourquoi parce
que le gouvernement de grand national
est appuyée par la turquie qui importent
sur le territoire libyen
des combattants syriens qui sont au
nombre significatif quand je dis en
nombre significatif c'est plusieurs
milliers et d'un autre côté côté haftar
dans une moindre mesure parce que les
forces sont moins importantes mais la
présence de la russie qui importe aussi
des combattants syrien mais pas les
mêmes et donc voilà la confrontation
devant laquelle nous sommes avec comment
dire le côté insupportable du fait que
monsieur rassam salamé qui était le
mandataire de secrétaire général des
nations unies ce qui provoqua les
réunions qui concernait avec tout le
monde à dieu pour des raisons
personnelles arrêté sa fonction et qui
n'est toujours pas remplacé et ça fait
quand même
non ça fait trois mois que ça dure trois
mois et il fallait que le catalyseur de
l'accord de berlin donc nous parlons le
présent la république et moi même nous
parlons y compris pendant cette période
avait avec tout le monde
pour essayer d'en revenir aux
fondamentaux de berlin ce qui veut dire
un accord de cessez le feu
la seule chose qui a qui a marché c'est
la réunion ce qu'on appelle le comité
militaire 5 + 50 de gens un peu dans la
technique qui regroupait cinq militaires
côté haftar cinq militaires côté côté
gouvernement
côté jeunes pour se mettre d'accord sur
les conditions d'un cessez-le-feu c'est
déjà pas mal
ils se sont mis d'accord le 23 février
dernier sauf que après personne c'est le
militaire mais les autres ne met pas en
oeuvre cet accord il faut commencer par
cela plus ce déblocage des terminaux
pétroliers et le dialogue interlibyen
tout ça est assez compliqué je vais me
rendre mon premier déplacement parce que
je pouvoir me déplacer à parler de la
semaine prochaine et d'aller en italie
pour m'entretenir avec les italiens de
cette de cette évolution
on ne peut pas imaginer une situation de
conflit tu alité de ce type i
signalisation à 200 kilomètres des côtes
européennes
donc ils pensent qu'ils n'apportent que
les uns et les autres nous puissions
agir auprès des uns et des autres pour
que l'on se remette dans le cycle
positif
nous discutons aussi avec des algériens
discutons aussi avec des égyptiens je
les fais encore hier sur ce sujet là
parlons avec eux les autorités et de
misrata et de
et de l'armée nationale ni bien deux
îles marshall haftar et nous essayons
avec les autres européens d'agir en ce
sens mais c'est une situation qui est
quand même aujourd'hui très préoccupante
je terminerai monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
parole jeffrey référence à la situation
au proche-orient et je terminerai par le
l'irak sur le proche orient
bon vous le savez après une longue phase
d'incertitude politique qui datait de
décembre 2018 et la ville il ya eu trois
élections législatives en inde en israël
ce procès cela vient de se terminer avec
un accord politique différentes forces
premier ministre monsieur netanyahou qui
va donner sa place à monsieur grand saut
dans deux ans deux ans et demi dix-huit
mois 18 mois donc un accord de ce type
mais vous ne vous a pas échappé que il y
a aussi une menace d'annexion partielle
de la cisjordanie puisque une partie de
l'accord politique a intégré cette
opportunité qui a été reprise par le
premier cette année ou dans son discours
d'introduction qui a eu lieu pas
dimanche dernier mais dimanche avant et
nous avons indiqué avec une grande
partie de nos partenaires européens que
si de telles mesures étaient mises en
vente 9
elle ne pourrait pas rester sans
conséquences sur les relations de
l'union européenne avec israël et nous
disons nous avait on a évoqué tout à
l'heure que ce serait aussi une
violation de l'un des principes
fondamentaux du droit international que
ce serait aussi une remise en cause de
manière l'aïr et versé de la solution
des deux états on a eu le temps
d'évoquer tout cela ici dans il ya
quelques temps donc je vais pas revenir
sur toutes les histoires mais j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire hier à l'assemblée
nationale que sid aventures des
initiatives de ce type été prises elles
ne pourraient pas rester sans réponse je
n'en dis pas plus mais je reste sur les
fondamentaux les fondamentaux pour la
france et le fait qu'il y ait un cadre
c'est le droit international la france
ne reconnaîtra aucune modification des
lignes de 1967 sauf celles à gré entre
les parties par la négociation
il y a une méthode c'est précisément la
négociation entre les deux parties au
conflit et donc ils n'apportent d'ouvrir
les négociations avec les autorités
palestiniennes et l'objectif ce sont
deux états viables vivant dans la paix
et la sécurité au sein de frontières
sûres et reconnues
ayant chacun jérusalem pour capitale
sont les principes que nous avons
toujours tenu
nous avons des relations positives avec
israël je vais m'entretenir avec mon
nouveau collègue dans pendant le
week-end nous avons aussi des relations
très très positive avec mes deux rues de
l'autorité palestinienne c'est sur ces
bases là que à mon avis nous devons agir
et pour cela nous le faisons dans trois
directions avec nos principaux
partenaires européens avec des messages
dissuasifs et coordonnée que nous menons
en ce moment de manière très active et
nous avons aussi des relations très
étroites avec des états arabes dits et
arabes modérés je pense en particulier à
la jordanie est aussi à l'egypte est
aussi à l'arabie saoudite qui a été à
l'origine de l'initiative de paix arabe
2000-2006 initiative 2002 avait démontré
positif que l'on peut peut-être
reprendre en tout cas nous sommes dans
cette logique là enfin sur l'irak qui
doit faire face à de nombreux défis à la
fois une crise la crise sanitaire
même si l'ampleur samples aujourd'hui
relativement contenu l'irak doit faire
face à une crise économique avec
l'effondrement du prix du pétrole dans
ce pays est très dépendant
l'irak doit faire face à des tensions
entre les etats-unis et l'iran dont
l'irak est prisonnière une certaine
manière directe d'en faire face à une
crise interne après des mois de
manifestations
l'irak va faire face à la poursuite de
la lutte contre edf qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas terminée comme le montrent des
attaques des derniers jours mais d'âge
profitent de la situation et des
attentats récents dèche lancent des
attaques dans en particulier dans les
provinces de diyala et de salaheddine
proche du site pétrolier faisant des
attaques faisant des morts dans la
mobilisation populaire mais aussi dans
les forces de sécurité irakiennes il y
as enfin nouveau gouvernement de celui
de monsieur khademi qui a été formé très
récemment qui représente une opportunité
pour l'irak
le président de la république s'est
entretenu avec lui ce week-end et il lui
a fait pas de détermination à travailler
avec son gouvernement pour contribuer à
la stabilité de l'irak dans le plein
respect de sa souveraineté
et dans ce cadre là notre priorité c'est
d'affirmer la souveraineté de l'irak
faire en sorte que ce gouvernement
puisse vraiment est inclusif dans la
diversité des composantes irakienne vous
connaissez bien le sujet monsieur
président parce que vous m'avez
accompagné une fois dedans ce pays et
faire en sorte aussi que pendant ce
temps nous puissions poursuivre le
combat contre d'âge parce qu'il n'est
pas s'achever
il n'est pas achevée parce que des chais
est toujours là et parce que il ya des
clans destin et parce que les attentats
se poursuivent et se poursuivre d'autant
plus facilement que tout le monde a les
yeux fixés sur d'autres sujets qui sont
très préoccupants qui sont les sujets de
la pandémie
voilà
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
quelques propos d'ouverture même si
j'étais un petit peu long mais je suis
toujours inconnues jeudi il est
tellement de sujets que je vais parfois
du mal à être bref et je l'effleuré
qu'une partie des sujets merci monsieur
le ministre de ce tour d'horizon
effectivement le nombre de crise est
telle que ça nécessitait quelques
développements
je reviens tout de suite et sans plus
attendre aux orateurs des groupes je
rappelle pour nos collègues qui
n'appartiennent pas au bureau que la
liste des orateurs tient compte de la
nouvelle des nouvelles dispositions qui
étaient arrêtés en eau au sein du bureau
qui permet de pondérer les prises de
parole en fonction de la
représentativité de chaque groupe la
parole est maintenant s'il m'entend et
s'il allume son micro sa caméra à robert
del picchia pour le groupe des
républicains
oui monsieur le président je m'entends
très bien et je vous vois bien monsieur
le ministre
alors le président a fait une bonne
synthèse au début sur des problèmes je
voulais revenir sur notre point c'est
une nouvelle dénonciation d'un accord
international du président américain
alors monsieur mahmoud habitués l'om et
se livrant les tweets etc
à chaque fois il ya une annonce et la
filiale annonce de cet open sky ciel
ouvert et ça nous préoccupe parce que je
crois que c'est quelque chose qui est
dangereux qui a eu du mal à se mettre en
place
maintenant il va falloir que les russes
suivent
est-ce qu'ils vont respecter leurs
obligations si ce n'est pas le cas qu'en
est-il de ciel ouvert
alors est ce que on connaît la position
de la france c'est celle des européens
on a regretté bien sûr le
secrétaire-général de l'otan a lancé un
appel aux rudes mais moi je me pose la
question qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
d'abord et puis que veulent les
américains que veut le président emprunt
en dénonçant cet accord deuxième
question très rapidement à l'amérique du
sud
bon c'est pas qu'on a appris que le coït
1,19 se développe au brésil en
particulier la situation est grave et
délicate
et puis un pays en amérique latine
qui a en plus de ces problèmes que les
problèmes politiques et de violence même
c'est le venezuela alors quelle est
notre position
et qu'est-ce qu'on attend il qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire dans cette situation je
vous remercie de bord et bronze mot
sionisme ercis robert maintenant pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain marie
françoise pérol dumont qui allume son
micro et sa caméra
voilà on devait suivre
c'est bien c'est bien on entend et on te
voit merci président monsieur le
ministre vous avez dressé un tableau
extrêmement compliqué extrêmement dense
je voudrais revenir sur quelques points
que vous n'allez pas aborder ou sur
lesquelles j'aime bien avoir quelques
précisions nous avait dit que personne
ne voulait anticiper la crise c'est bien
dans son ampleur pourtant si le coville
19 a pris une grande partie de
l'humanité par surprise les services de
renseignement mondiaux avaient alerté
sur cette épidémie
ils ont cependant été largement comment
dirais-je ignoré du moins peut écouter
à telle enseigne que d'anciens hauts
responsables de la dgse souligne qu'il
n'y a pas eu de défaillance de la part
des services extérieurs français mais
bien plutôt je cite un problème de
définition et de prévoyance des
politiques
les services auraient donc fait leur
travail mais leurs analyses et leurs
salaires n'auraient pas été suivies
d'effet
vous ne pensez vous pas monsieur le
ministre que comme les attentats du 11
septembre avaient profondément modifier
notre appréhension du risque terroriste
cette pandémie doit modifier leur
appréhension du risque sanitaire et on
ne peut pas occulter le risque que les
deux soient liés comment envisagez-vous
d'intégrer messieurs be nice
cette préoccupation à l'avenir la
deuxième question porte sur les tensions
entre paris et pékin autour de taiwan
est aussi un petit peu avec hong kong
alors que la chine tente plus que jamais
d'étendre son empire sur taïwan et hong
kong la chine il ya quinze jours a
demandé à la france d'annuler un contrat
d'armement avec le gouvernement
indépendante taipei et dansions qui très
certainement s'inscrivent dans la lignée
de la provocation de l'ambassadeur de
chine à paris après ses propos sur le
coronel virus
quel rôle peut jouer notre pays
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le ministre
qu'il serait utile en termes j'allais
dire stratégique que nous conclurons a
minima tant qu'ong que taiwan
quand on voit les ambitions hégémoniques
de lâcher des chinois en mer de chine ma
question suivante vous en avez parlé un
petit peu mais je n'avais pas être
développées complètement elle porte sur
le processus d'annexion éventuelle de la
cisjordanie
vous nous aviez dit vous avez dit que
avec seulement deux pays vous a lancé de
riposte éventuel quelle forme pourrait
prendre cette riposte us tiré pour faire
court quel véritable poids les européens
peuvent avoir dans ce conflit
un point qui n'a pas été abordé non plus
monsieur le ministre mais votre celi
beaucoup de choses à dire c'est la
situation en russie
la situation sanitaire économique en
russie n'est pas bonne elle est même
dramatique dit certains observateurs la
situation sociale est préoccupante
quel impact cette dégradation sur le
plan intérieur peut-elle avoir selon
vous sur la stratégie russe à l'échelle
internationale notamment sur les terres
de l'opération syrien et libyen
pensez-vous par ailleurs que la russie
renforcera d'autant plus son influence
et sa présence en méditerranée orientale
avec quels risques pour les équilibres
régionaux
enfin le dernier point pour être bref
monsieur le ministre il n'est pas du
tout géopolitique mais plusieurs de mes
collègues tenait à ce que je vous en
parle c'est la situation de
d'autocaristes français depardon belle
gueule comme ça s'appelle les personnes
qui ont des camping-cars et qui sont au
maroc
ce sont en général des retraités qui
n'ont pas nécessairement de traits de
pouvoir d'achat qui sont bloqués là-bas
et qui se demandent encore comment ils
vont revenir
je sais que certains n'ont pas été
raisonnable au début de la pandémie et
que comptez vous faire pour eux je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
merci marie françoise maintenant au nom
du groupe union centriste olivier
cigolotti merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre ouane points
rapidement
notre président l'a dit effectivement
pendant que le monde compte les mordus
du cornât les russes les crises ne cesse
d'augmenter à travers le monde
vous avez parfaitement résumé la
situation en libye notamment en
rappelant la conférence internationale
de berlin qui prévoyait effectivement un
embargo sur les armes
or en réalité ces derniers affluent de
toutes parts et ce selon un récent
rapport de l'onu
des avions de chasse russes viennent en
soutien au général haftar dans l'est de
la libye des sociétés de sécurité
émirati temps d'empêcher les navires
turcs d'acheminer des armes pour le
gouvernement d'union nationale
sans revenir dans le détail pensez vous
monsieur le ministre quand une
résolution du conflit libyen soit encore
possible et à quelque niveau que ce soit
est ce que la concertation avec les
autres pays membres de l'union
européenne est encore possible pour
essayer d'atténuer la situation en libye
deuxième point concerne la chine et
notamment le double jeu des autorités
chinoises qui persistent dans des
postures ambigu double jeu en birmanie
en pékin entretient des relations à la
fois avec le gouvernement birman et avec
les groupes rebelles
double jeu en corée du nord double jeu
au niveau de la pandémie
et quand on voit des tonnes de matériel
humanitaire dans le monde entier et en
même temps pékin formule de vives
critiques et répliques ouvertement à
certaines démocraties occidentales
monsieur le ministre cette stratégie des
plus ambiguës n'était pas destinée à
conquérir de nouveaux pays amis à les
rendre dépendants effectivement des deux
chinoises sur la scène internationale à
la veille d'une nouvelle guerre froide
avec les états unis quelle stratégie
l'europe doit-elle développer le chef de
la diplomatie européenne josé bord elle
s'inquiète lui même de l'assurance que
prend la chine et de sa montée en
puissance
merci de vos réponses merci olivier
le deuxième intervenant pour les
républicains bruno sido monsieur le
ministre
cette audition est l'occasion de
poursuivre notre mission de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement
mission à laquelle d'ailleurs le
président du sénat tient
particulièrement
tout comme man group ces trois derniers
mois et les agenda diplomatique ont été
dédiés à la lutte contre le coc vide 19
et à ses conséquences économiques
force est de constater que les
problématiques relatives au terrorisme à
la prolifération des armes aux drogues
et aux trafics humains n'ont pas disparu
or l'union européenne fait face à un
nouveau double défi à savoir résister
sanitairement en plus de relancer son
économie et remettre ses finances en bon
ordre mais cela ne doit pas faire
oublier la réalité des équilibres
mondiaux d'où mes questions la première
c'est comment se positionne comment se
positionne l'union européenne sur la
scène diplomatique
à l'heure de la lutte pour le leadership
mondial et la sempiternelle guerre
commerciale entre les états unis et la
chine qui fait fi de tous ceux qui
incarnent le multilatéralisme ont pesé
dans le concert des nations est encore
une ambition européenne où la réalité
des difficultés structurelles de l'union
at-elle eu raison de cette volonté
c'était ma deuxième question
nous précisément en europe depuis
bientôt quatre ans on nous devons
traiter et négocier un brésil qui n'en
finit plus et dont la complexité est
telle que nous focalisons principalement
nous nous focalisons principalement sur
des modalités commerciales
doudou la troisième question où en outre
le volet économique négocié via
bruxelles et grâce au travail tout à
fait remarquable d'ailleurs de michel
barnier et le cadre de défense instauré
par les accords de lancaster house quel
est l'agenda de et le cadre de nos
futures relations avec le royaume uni
sur le volet de la défense et de la et
diplomatique la france ne perd t'elle
pas un allié dans sa vision de défense
et de sécurité en europe et en
particulier au moment où au niveau
européen certains pays demandent que
l'union européenne est un siège au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu et enfin où
en sommes-nous sur le volet migratoires
notamment dans les négociations avec la
turquie alors que l'accord est arrivé à
son terme
sachant que depuis la crise du coup vite
29 s'y ajoute désormais maintenant un
volet sanitaire
je vous remercie merci bruno pour le
groupe la république en marche bernard
cazeau monsieur le ministre merci de
tout ce que vous avez évoqué dans le
cadre de la pandémie je voudrais poser
deux questions une plus plus
particulièrement lié à votre évocation
de la pandémie dans le monde et l'autre
pu publier peut-être au problème du
moyen orient dans le cadre de cette
flambée pandémique
on n'a pas parlé du duduk du problème
du brésil particulièrement du
militantisme dont fait preuve monsieur
molson arrow qui entraîne une flambée
épidémique formidable dans ce pays avec
touchant particulièrement d'ailleurs les
populations défavorisées et ceci a une
répercussion sur un de nos territoires
d'outre-mer la guyane puisqu'on assiste
à une reprise épidémique très importante
dans ce territoire notamment dans la
partie limitrophe brésilienne du fait
des réfugiés brésilien grands noms qui
fut le nord-est qui est assez peu
protégés du fait de cette politique liée
à la politique de monsieur bos au nord
je voudrai savoir si il ya une hyène y
at il une intervention possible de la
france sur ceux sur sur cette affaire et
surtout sur cette porosité du territoire
brésilien vis-à-vis du territoire de
notre territoire d'autres merck et la
guyane
la première question sa deuxième est
plutôt lié à une évocation que vous avez
détaillé celle de l'irak ton pays auquel
je je m'intéresse particulièrement comme
vous le savez c'est vrai que après cinq
mois de crise politique
l'irak s'est doté d'un nouveau premier
ministre monsieur al kadhim il part il
paraît qu'ils entretiennent de bonnes
relations à la fois ont des relations
cordiales avec les deux protagonistes
16h02 roi des états unis et l'iran
quoi qu'il en soit les finances du pays
sont exemple vous l'avez dit les pays
pratiquement en faillite
les fonctionnaires ne sont plus payés ou
pratiquement pas l'administration ne
fonctionne de ce fait au ralenti du fait
de ce pétrole à moins de 20 dollars
mais vous savez que 90 % ou plus de 90%
d'ailleurs de la richesse eux ont des
finances irakiennes viennent du pétrole
les cures de le les relations avec les
kurdes redeviennent conflictuelle tu
fait aussi encore du partage de recettes
de ce pétrole les manifestations sont
encore très actifs vous l'avez dit sur
la place taille à bagdad
et pour couronner tout ça ils sont
confrontés comme nous même si c'est
moins important semble-t-il au coït 19
et au problème comme vous l'avez dit
dèche
alors bien sûr vous nous dit on la
souveraineté de l'irak où la firme ont
certes nous affirmant la souveraineté de
l'irak
mais comment voyez vous l'avenir de
l'irak à court et moyen terme est ce que
la france ne pourrait pas du fait de
cette justement de cette recrudescence
du phénomène des seiches d'intervenir
plus efficacement tour merci merci
bernard en direct de marseille pour le
rassemblement démocratique social
européen c'est jean noël guérini bonjour
président bonjour monsieur le ministre
trois questions sont ici il me répéter
par rapport à mes collègues la crise
sanitaire a paradoxalement rapprocher
paris et berlin
la commission engage l arbitrage entre
la proposition le vol avait indiqué de
relance formulée par le président de la
république madame merkel qui a provoqué
l'opposition de quatre pays que l'on
appelle frugaux si vous le permettez
l'autriche le danemark les pays bas et
la suède
ma question mais la diplomatie et
économie ne battons pas assister l
approfondissement de la fracture nord
sud dans la zone euro et la volonté
annoncée de relocaliser certaines
productions n'avantagera pas certains
pays
ma deuxième question le ministre
problème aujourd'hui nous nous donner
des informations sur la situation de
romain nadal notre ambassadeur de france
au venezuela
quelles démarches ont elles été engagés
pour médecins et confinement
inacceptable du représentant de la
république dans ce pays plongé dans cru
une crise profonde et enfin depuis
bientôt un an farida abel cas chercheuse
franco iranienne est emprisonnée en iran
le 16 mai dernier l'avait condamné à
cinq ans de prison pour collusion en vue
d'attenter à la sûreté nationale et un
an au pack 2 contre le système politique
de la république islamiste
quels sont les blocages et entrave sa
libération
au delà de la décision de justice et
ensuite qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
mais seul ministre des relations de la
france avec l'iran dans un contexte de
tension tréport en traité en héros
washington je vous remercie
merci jean noël je précise comme élément
de réponse que nous aurons romain nadal
notre ambassadeur de france angles en
colombie le venezuela pardon le dit le
10 juin en audition alors maintenant
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologistes christine pruneaux
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre merci de votre présence et de
votre intervention
moi je n'ai abordé plusieurs questions
mais je devais prendre la dimension
internationale de la pro b
développé sur le moyen-orient est
principalement sur la palestine
non pas que c'est forcément notre cheval
de bataille de hoth sérieux mais
figurez-vous lors d'une audition en
avril avec le directeur de recherche de
l'irsn sur le moyen-orient
j'ai donc posé une question sur les
conditions sanitaires en palestine
je n'ai eu aucune réponse
j'ai eu une réponse correcte mais le
directeur m'a précisé qu'il n'avait pas
de chiffre à donner et que ce n'était
pas dans dans ses compétences ses
compétences ou par discrétion je ne sais
donc je pense surtout pour avoir un peu
plus d'informations nous avons des
chiffres
quand on parle d'israël on donne des
chiffres alors est-ce qu'il d'israël
considère que les chiffres de
cisjordanie font déjà partie du pays
d'israël c'est c'est à se demander mais
vous comprenez bien que nous sommes
inquiets vu déjà une condition pas
seulement politique mais aussi de
pauvreté dans lequel vit gaza
principalement mais aussi la nano la
cisjordanie donc je vais me reposer les
questions
je lui avais posé au moins en partie
c'était est ce que la france participe à
des pas des bons à rien je sais que
c'est impossible mais à des couloirs
sanitaire c'est à dire au moins que les
gazaouis ou le site jordanien puisse
aller se faire soigner dans certains
hôpitaux en israël puisqu'il n'ont pas
toutes les structures sur place mais
comme ils n'ont pas des droits de
circulation
vous savez que c'est à compte-gouttes
donc maintenant je pense que c'est pire
mais le contexte politique
pouvez vous me dire comment ça se passe
et si nous avons une affluence - au
moins médical puisque les ong aussi sont
très réduites dans leur mouvement
donc avec vous des précisions sur la
situation sanitaire en palestine
et puis j'aurai une deuxième question
bien sûr on est que je trouve qu'on n'a
pas assez de temps pour développer cette
question est là j'espère qu'on aura des
bacs futur pour me vous nous l'aviez
posée
et ils vous l'avait fait il ya quelques
temps vous avez apprécié c'est par
rapport au plan train une femme et le
plan dit de paix qui devraient être
votées et présenté au vote le 1er
juillet je crois qu'il manque de temps
pour être vraiment réactif hocini
parlementaire parce que là vous ne
parlez plus dall'igna sion ce ministre
et j'en suis fort thèse et vous parlais
de réponse mais nous ne savons pas quoi
déjà moi je l'avais demandé le groupe
l'avait demandé et si aussi quelle que
soit la couleur politique
la fin du blocus a déjà ça c'est ce
qu'il y aurait de plus facile à faire
quelle que soit quelle que soit notre
musique notre influence je ne sais où on
est maintenant sur ce sujet là mais au
niveau sanitaire stopper arrêter le
blocus en palestine serait quand même ce
qu'il y aurait de plus de plus cette
annonce ses tables de bon sens pour moi
en france je ne vois pas pourquoi on on
aborderait pas ce thème de suite avant
de même de parler de riposte voilà je ne
fais pas pu voir ce que j'aurais aimé
développer ce dernier pas plus largement
mais j'essaie gros on va le faire soit
sinistre merci christine alors enfin au
titre des groupes pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
jean louis lagourgue prix merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre il ya
quelques semaines comme beaucoup de nos
compatriotes
j'ai été quelque peu perturbée en
entendant les propos tenus par l'un des
dirigeants de laboratoire pharmaceutique
français
concernant la primaire qui sera réservé
aux états unis en cas de découverte d'un
vaccin contre le coronavirus évidemment
je peux comprendre qu'il faut des
financements pour axe et accélérer la
recherche et à ce titre les états unis
on s'est tellement apporté une
contribution non négligeable
toutefois face à cette crise sanitaire
sans précédent qui à ce jour a touché
près de 6 millions de personnes et fait
plus de trois cent mille morts
je reste persuadé que c'est notre esprit
de solidarité internationale qui doit
l'emporter sur les intérêts mercantiles
je voudrais donc monsieur le ministre
connaître votre point de vue sur ce
sujet et plus globalement savoir et la
stratégie de la france en matière de
collaboration musicale avec les autres
pays du monde pour exact éradiquer
spirit vous avez répondu en partie
quid également de la position de nos
voisins dans le cadre de cette
coopération européenne annoncée par le
président la république est temps
aujourd'hui idéalement dans une logique
de partage des savoir-faire et des
compétences au fil du vent non où
sommes-nous plutôt dans une démarche de
chacun pour soi enfin monsieur le
ministre notre collègue robert là où
foule ou sénateurs de wallis qui est
bloquée ankara à 14h l'obligatoire à
bord d'un navire au large ou alice me
demandent de vous soumettre deux points
qui le préoccupe
le premier concerne le blocage à fidji
depuis plus de deux mois de quelques
personnes originaire de wallis et futuna
et qui bien sûr devant le rapatriement
il souhaiterait connaître les raisons
pour lesquelles ils sont toujours
bloqués et les actions de vos services
pourraient avancer leur situation ils
s'inquiètent par ailleurs de la
situation vanuatu suite aux cyclones
harold qui a ravagé cet archipel l'île
de santo la plus francophone vanuatu a
été très lourdement touchés et le maire
de la capitale de cette île a demandé
l'aide de l'ambassade de france qui ne
peut répondre faute de moyens le
sénateur là où foule ou souhaiterait
donc que notre pays fasse un geste que
la reconstruction de la mairie qui a été
construite par la france avant
l'indépendance et dont la chine voudrait
financer la réhabilitation ce qui
symboliquement serait regrettable
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
merci jean louis messieurs me disait la
parole pour répondre nos intervenants
des groupes pas je vais essayer monsieur
le président il ya de quoi refaire toute
l'histoire du monde je sais
c'est donc qu'il passait peut-être une
partie de ces fonds que vous veniez plus
mais si vous me permettez je vais juste
faire une observation pour monsieur la
gur puisqu'il vient de me poser des
problèmes très ponctuel d'abord s'il
m'entend bien sûr le coronavirus et la
lutte contre le coronavirus vaccin le
traitement
moi je crois avoir tout dit j'ai passé
je crois un pas de quart d'heure vous
exposez je crois là la stratégie que
nous avons c'est une stratégie à la fois
française heureux et européennes
mobilisatrice entente de financement
nouveau il s'agit aussi au sein de l'
oms c'est dans ce cadre là les
déclarations d'un responsable de sanofi
d'abord ils sont les responsables sont
revenu dessus et en plus c'est une
manière de répondre globalement et je
crois positivement sur la nécessité de
considérer que les vaccins les
traitements doivent être prises en
compte comme bien commun mondial d'un
coma de l'humanité est considéré comme
tel par l'ensemble des pays
c'est la résolution qui étaient prises à
l'eau et metz au début de ce mois et il
faudra la mettre la mettre en oeuvre
ça veut dire des engagements précis des
acteurs je vais reprendre tout ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure mais je pense
qu'il y avait l'essentiel de notre
stratégie
à cet égard je suis au courant de la
situation de blocage de quelques uns de
nos compatriotes fidji on les suit de
prêt techniquement le centre de crise
est bien informé de cela
j'espère qu'on va trouver une solution
qui n'est pas simple ce qu'il ya aussi
les les mesures de ces jeux le dis à
tout le monde ici on a permis le retour
de 186 milles de nos ressortissants
ceux là font partie de ces filles et ce
serait née supplémentaires et encore
quelques personnes quelques cas isolés
je parle pas des camping-cars et sur
lequel je vais revenir mais c'est
toujours très difficile parce que quand
les pays sont très loin qu'ils ont fermé
leurs frontières et que les pays voisins
ont aussi fermé leurs frontières qui a
pu 2 d'espacés aériens ouverts
c'est pas simple et donc on a été
confrontés à des cas très compliqué et
sur celui là pour l'instant on n'a pas
encore la solution mais je suis
convaincu qu'en relation avec d'ailleurs
avec des pays voisins on pourra la
trouver et sur le vanuatu je suis bien
au courant aussi de la situation de des
prétentions chinoise ramène à une autre
un autre débat sur ce territoire et nous
sommes très très vigilants pour qu'il
puisse y avoir les moyens nécessaires
après cet ouragan
voilà pour monsieur lagourgue commencé
j'ai commencé en sens inverse mais comme
c'étaient des points précis je me
permettait d'y répondre là sur monsieur
del picchia sur le fait que les
etats-unis auront renoncé au traité dit
traité ciel ouvert c'est à la fois
désolant et désarmant si je peux me
permettre cette expression parce que
c'est le troisième accord de non
prolifération et troisième accord de
désarmement dans l'administration
annonce ou américaines annoncent vouloir
se retirer alors que ce traité existait
depuis il était signé en 1992 à alcine
qui il était en vie entre en vigueur
beaucoup plus tard en 2002 le prétexte
c'est que la russie aurait une gestion
un peu particulière de ce traité
d'entraidé au dessus de l'emploi de
kaliningrad
ça ne semble pas aussi fort que cela
même si on peut être vigilant sur
l'application du traité nous sommes 35
états dans ce traité et donc nous
restons partie à ce traité mais il faut
qu'on analyse avec nos partenaires
européens à l'impact du retrait des
états unis comment là la russie va
bouger mais elle déclare pour l'instant
ne pas vouloir se retirer
ça nous ramène à une
un constat que je fais ici depuis déjà
plusieurs mois
le fait que les outils du
multilatéralisme et singulièrement les
outils liés de la fin de désaccord de la
fin du siècle dernier sur le désarmement
sont tentera de se défaire
progressivement avec le retrait d'un
dédain des partenaires ce qui nous amène
un propre responsabilité de la sécurité
européenne
en tout cas pour la pour notre part la
france n'a pas l'intention de quitter
cet accord vous m'avez interrogé voilà
pour le ciel ouvert s'est passé un peu
inaperçu mais vous avez raison de le
souligner c'est parce que dans le
mouvement
autant sur leurs traites gcp hoa et du
fmi
ça fait fait beaucoup de bruit là pas du
tout alors que c'est tout à fait tout à
fait regrettable
c'étaient des mesures de confiance
mutuelle au niveau de la sécurité du
ciel sur le brésil et le venezuela
du coup je vais répondre en un temps à
d'autres questions monsieur cazaux puis
une autre question sur venezuela sur
monsieur nadal nous nous avons sur le
brésil ni préoccupation parce que la
manière de gérer
la pandémie est particulière je sais pas
si je peux dire ça comme ça
spécifiques c'est de la gestion de des
autorités brésiliennes donc moi je n'ai
pas à prendre position sur la manière
dont monsieur sun araw estime devoir
gérer cette crise il n'empêche que nous
sommes soucieux de voir la progression
du nombre de victimes et la rapidité de
progression du virus et j'ai entendu je
le dis avec modération puisque je suis
en audition publique mais je crois qu'il
fut un temps comparé les gestion
démocratique de la crise et les gestions
dit populiste de la crise je sais pas si
c'est ici ou dans les médias
j'observe que le président trump vient
de fermer ses frontières à l'égard du
brésil nous je laisse cette constatation
à notre réflexion intellectuelle commune
sur quel est le meilleur moyen de lutter
contre
les recalés bayal mobiliser des mesures
pour lutter contre l'épidémie
la pandémie je constate lorsqu'il y à la
transparence et la confiance comme ça
s'est passé en france ou non disait un
moment donné jamais les français ne sont
capables de faire comme les chinois ou
anne rappelez vous au mois de janvier on
constatait la manière dont s'était passé
à one et commet plusieurs millions de
chinois s'était confiné à ce moment là
je lisais des papiers comme prévu jamais
en france soit possible à 6 par la
mobilisation commune la transparence et
le respect du droit
parce que pendant tout ce temps là le
droit a été respecté
l'assemblée nationale a fonctionné le
sénat a fonctionné et la presse étaient
libres et nous avons pu être à ce rendez
vous là donc je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faudra faire les comparaisons
final sur la meilleure manière de lutter
en terme politique contre cette pandémie
nous sommes préoccupés de cette
situation mais nous avons je le dis je
suis un peu lent de la réponse est
monsieur picchia mais je pourrais moi
d'autres en même temps nous avons une
collaboration avec certains états
fédérés pour les aider dans la lutte
contre cette pandémie nous apportons
aussi notre soutien aux autorités
sanitaires du pays y compris dans une
très grande vigilance à l'égard de la
guyane je prie monsieur le ministre
c'est ma question était surtout centré
là dessus la porosité de la frontière
fait qu'il ya une recrudescence mais
très important d'après les élus
sénateurs du tracteur sur la guyane tout
à fait donc le centre est occupé la
situation la ministre de l'outre-mer a
évoqué cette question ce matin même au
conseil des ministres
nous sommes très très vigilants sur
cette situation guyane bien sûr c'est là
la plus grande difficulté avec mayotte
dans les territoires dans les dom tom
sur la situation venait lui est là où la
crise pandémique s'ajoute à la crise
politique et est la crise migratoire
nous avons tenu hier une conférence de
financement pour les réfugiés et les
migrants vénézuélien qui était organisé
par par l'espagne la france il ya
contribué
c'était une visioconférence qui montre
la mobilisation qui existe autour de ces
réfugiés singulièrement dans les pays
voisins qui les accueillent donc c'était
deux tracés significative en appui du
hcr et de l'om pour qu'elle puisse
parvenir aux îles compris à l'intérieur
du territoire vénézuélien
aujourd'hui la situation politique et
reste ne change pas il y a eu un épisode
un peu compliqué avec le l'opération
dite vidéo où il ya une tentative de
coup d'état pour renverser le président
maduro c'était une opération qui
sembleraient avoir été organisée par un
ancien marine américain mais on ne peut
pas être certain de tous les éléments
qui ont contribué à cette tentative de
renversement mais en tout cas pour
aujourd'hui nous sommes tout à fait
décidée à poursuivre nos actions pour
permettre une sortie politique de cette
crise l'europe sous la responsabilité du
haut représentant organise ce qu'on
appelle un ce qu'on appelle le groupe de
contact avec plusieurs pays d'amérique
du sud pour essayer d'aboutir à une
solution politique et des élections
libres
mais c'est aujourd'hui difficile et les
solutions de compromis sont pas très
très avancé à l'heure actuelle et pour
ferrer quoi ce que vous indiquez
concernant notre ambassadeur à caracas
j'ai été amené à plusieurs reprises a
convoqué l'ambassadeur du venezuela à
paris pour lui faire part de mes
observations je n'en dirai pas plus
voilà pour monsieur del picchia madame
eyrolles dumont moi je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous surtout le scénario
autour des services secrets et de
l'agenda que vous évoquez je m'en tiens
au fait qu'ils sont portés à ma
connaissance et non pas aux supputations
qui sont portés à la connaissance
d'autres les faits qui sont portées à ma
connaissance c'est le 31 décembre il y a
eu une première référence à l'hypothèse
d'un cas de
cette épidémie à l'époque on appelait
épidémie a one et il ya eu un article de
presse dans la presse taïwanaise le 2
janvier les sur un autre cas mais à
l'époque personne n'imaginait que
c'était deux coqs qui allait précipiter
cette pandémie
puis les autorités chinoises ont fait
une déclaration publique mi mi janvier
pour faire valoir la gravité d'une
situation qui a qui a abouti à ce que
nous puissions prendre des initiatives
pour évacuer nos ressortissants de one
la déclaration de des autorités
chinoises
mi-janvier le confinement à once et le
23 janvier et abat ce moment là nous
avons organisé des retours de
ressortissants par deux vols dont
j'assume totalement la responsabilité je
crois qu'ils auront de plus nous avons
confiné nos ressortissants dans le sud
de la france pendant quinze jours et
ensuite ils ont pu retourner à leur
domicile
c'était aussi l'observation que monsieur
djibo leity mme v l'avait sollicité sur
vence et d'information je lui donne est
donc il n'y a pas d'autres choses à dire
et pour ma part aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas d'autres faits qui nous permettrait
de dire autre chose mais si quelqu'un en
a scientifiquement appuyé qu'il le dise
mais aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas
donc je n'ai pas de votre d'autres
éléments à dire voilà pour cette
audition de jean yves le drian le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères devant les sénateurs il a
dressé le bilan de la situation
internationale de l'épidémie de
coronavirus c'est la fin de cette
émission
merci de l'avoir suivi pour rester
informé sur cette crise sanitaire
n'hésitez pas à aller sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr je vous souhaite
une très bonne journée et un très bon
week-end sur public sénat
[Musique]